Democrats 30 years ago would be shocked
at what has happened to their party if
they could fast forward decades they
wouldn't recognize it all of a sudden
the party as a party is aggressively
sexualizing children not just drag queen
story hours not just the mutilation of
children's sexual mutilation of gender
ideology but pushing graphic
sexualization in schools on little kids
and at the same time many of our leaders
are refusing to punish pedophiles so
Stephanie Lord is a state representative
in New Mexico and has noticed this and
she's tried to get a couple of bills
passed that punish child sex abusers and
they've been rejected by democrats so
now she has a new idea her idea is
chemical castration isn't just for kids
how about doing it to pedophiles too
Stephanie Lord is a New Mexico state
representative she joins us tonight
Stephanie thank you so much for coming
on so rather than have us characterize
your idea if you wouldn't mind
explaining what it is
thank you Tucker It's honor to be on
your show and I'm very grateful to be
here and I'm glad you're giving me this
opportunity to talk about this so I want
to make something really clear in New
Mexico the majority of people in our
state are moderate Democrats but
unfortunately we've got some Progressive
Democrats that are pushing forward some
radical ideology so my first session
when I was up here I there was quite a
few bills to be soft on criminals let
criminals out give them you know special
things that they wouldn't normally have
so I kept presenting amendments that
said okay well you want to let the
criminals out early how about not
pedophiles how about we don't be nice
and don't give them special treatment
yeah yeah how about that and so I even
presented an amendment about let's not
let them cut children's hair because
that idea actually disgusts me to have
them put their hands on children and
every amendment I presented was shot
down literally so it really got me
thinking so what can I do what is
something that I can do in this next
session when I got reelected what can I
do and I happen to see this bill in
Tennessee that was based off the Alabama
bill on chemical castration I looked I
thought this is a great idea this is a
way to a tool that we can use to keep
these pedophiles away from our children
that's all that I wanted that's all I
ever wanted out of this
so have you considered calling it
puberty blockers
if you did that maybe it may be every
Democrat in New Mexico would vote for it
that's a great idea well that is what's
frustrating it's it's the it's it's the
few progresses that we have because we
have some actually really good Democrats
but I know the progressive ideology has
taken over and it's frustrating because
I was a Democrat until 1997. I don't
even recognize a party anymore
um but yeah you know the whole goal for
me I'm very passionate and it comes from
my heart I just don't want pedophiles to
get any special treatment or to be
allowed early out of out of prison
well I've got to think no I know New
Mexico and you're right it's a very
moderate State mostly Democrats I would
think the majority of people in New
Mexico the voters should be in favor of
this
yes I think the voters are definitely in
favor of this because I don't know
anybody that's on the side of pedophiles
the problem is is that I have more
leeway on my side of the party I can
disagree with my party all day long and
I do they'll tell you that if I don't
feel that something is correct or right
for my district I won't vote for them
but I think there's more of a push on
their side where they have to align and
it's all or nothing yeah so I think they
got some pushback on that and that's
really unfortunate that's really really
unfortunate yeah I think that's a really
smart Insight they stick together that's
where their power is they know it
um yeah and it works unfortunately
Stephanie Lord thank you so much for
joining us tonight